Hey, what's going on is bill burn
is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
Just checking in on you.
Whatever the fuck I used to do it.
Uh, my warrior, I'm in Winnipeg,
Canada.
I didn't bring all my recording equipment,
so I'm going to figure the level here
that I can talk close to the thing without
fucking up yours. I'm in Winnipeg,
Canada. And guess what? It's still cold.
It's May 18th and it's like 42
degrees out, which it's annoying.
Why does it keep making that noise?
I'm not getting any closer to, oh,
it's the wind. I see. Keep it
steady. If I just rested on my chest,
will that work? How's
that? Okay, good. Anyways,
it's like 43 fucking degrees out,
you know,
which isn't cold for the wintertime,
but for May it's fucking annoying.
You know? And I didn't dress properly. I
came up here with the wind fucking break
and uh, you know, just walking around even
a zip up, my God damn coach and knowing,
Oh bill, fuck you. Everything
in noise. You, well, maybe
you're right. Maybe it does.
Maybe it does.
Um,
I don't know whether I'm just going
to hold this fucking recorder. Um,
I'll tell you, you know what's fucking
overrated by the way? Breakfast, potatoes,
breakfast potatoes, Cole
slaw, beans and rice.
All right.
All of them just taken up a fucking
chair on the bench that someone else who
wants to get in the fucking game
could be, you know, you just dump all,
like the like just rebuild,
start over again.
Like the fucking capitals,
you know, play fillers,
that's all it is. Fuck.
Breakfast potatoes,
they never tastes good and they just
make you fat and you feel like you got to
eat them because your mother was
always like, well, if you know,
fucking finish that you're going
to sit there until the morning.
And he just sat there, right?
Watching the ketchup dry, um,
turned in that it actually starts,
you know, coagulating Cetera.
Is that the right word? Um, anyways,
I don't understand why this fucking
record is going to have to be like this,
making all this racket. So I'm
trying to be a grump here. Um,
so I'm in Winnipeg tonight
for two, two shows. Um,
and then I go up to Saskatoon,
Saskatchewan wall,
scas, Saskatchewan, right. Um,
also known as the Paris of the prairies,
which to me is the greatest fucking
nickname of a city than I can.
What do you, what do you, what
again, the big apple that stinks.
Beantown horrific. The Berg. Terrible.
Does la even have a nickname?
Trying to think of the elements.
Okay.
The land. CLEVELAND, Ugh.
That whole fucking thing where all of
a sudden every goddamn city needed,
I know I always talk about this, but
I'll never get over that. The awful low,
is that what they call buffalo?
The Paris of the prairies?
How great is that?
You know what I mean? See you going
out there. Just the prayer is,
it's going to be a little
mom and pop type of shit,
but it's going to be beautiful.
Um,
go in there and then we go down to a
Regina afterwards, which I believe,
yeah. What's that nickname? A
twat city. Is that what it is?
Something like that or was that the
Golden State Warriors? I don't know.
Speaking of which I s the only way you
can root for the Golden State Warriors is
if you bet on them or if you're
from the Golden State, Oakland,
you know area in, you're
already a fan. Jesus Christ.
It was already bad enough to rent piled
on there and killed the OKC golden state
rivalry, which is what we
will be watching right now.
Yeah.
Instead you're literally listening to
announcements like last night when the
Celtics were playing Reggie Miller's
like going cause they're trying to sell
this series going Lego,
you know the only was booked then.
I mean some of it was good,
but just telling points it,
Reggie Miller goes, goes,
look,
we both know there's two meteors,
head that at one another and we're
just going to watch him collide.
So I'm trying to do the last time I
watched the eastern and Western conference
finals and they felt like the
first round of the playoffs.
I'm fucking warriors. Oh my
God, they're filthy. Filthy.
I love Popovich.
Going off on that fucking goof.
How many slides steps did he fucking take
to make sure his foot was going to be in
the vicinity of where Leonard was going
to land? And for somebody out there
who doesn't think that that's filthy?
Give me a fucking break. Give me a
break. He's taken a shot. You know,
why did he have to take that last
little slide step, skip, skip, skip,
and then just have his
fucking foot right there.
It'd be one thing if they couldn't do
like an entire highlight reel of him not
only being a dirty bastard,
but actually trying to
fucking whatever pop,
what's his face is Leonard shoulder out
or whatever the hell he was doing at
that time when he dragged him down
to the ground. It's a piece of shit.
The only thing worse than that fucking
move that he made was that awful little
debt.
Three skip and a hop thing that he did
afterwards as he was holding onto his
head. Like he couldn't fucking
believe it. Um, listen,
what the fuck do I know about who?
But I know Popovich knows a lot about
hoop and I know he's gone through a lot of
shit and he's gone through
a lot of playoff series.
I never seen him go off like that,
so I'm going to go with what he said as
opposed to when I was watching ESPN and
the fucking sports anchor goes to Steven
[inaudible]. Hey Steven. You know,
we've both played the game.
What do you think it is?
Fucking anchor sitting there,
you know,
he's going to question
Popovich and Steven A.
Smith who I love was just like,
he basically said,
what I'm saying with Popovich
says, it's true then. Yeah,
you kinda gotta go with that. But, um,
the biggest fucking story and hoop had
already came and went because the fucking
Cavaliers series with the Celtics already
started and they fucking kicked our
ass. Um, was,
I owe a certain member of the
Boston Celtics, a big apology
all of this time doubting camp,
you know,
making fun of his choice of sneakers,
making fun of the way he
looked in those sneakers,
talking about how many times he was
on the wrong side of the poster.
Kelly all fucking Linux.
What happened?
The man simply took over the game
in a fourth quarter of a game.
Seven for the Boston Celtics
were in the green and white
shades of,
of Cedric Maxwell.
Okay.
But one game we say, just get on my back
cause I'm fucking taken this thing home.
And that's exactly what he did.
Okay. Scored 14 points in the, uh,
the fourth quarter,
he took Isaiah Thomas' watch off and
put it on his own fucking risks and I'll
put down the court. He went,
he was back in, guys down,
he was fucking dunk.
Eddie was layups.
He was hitting threes
on fucking believable.
Now having said that,
he did it once.
So game one of the Cavaliers series,
he was right back to the Kelly
Olynyk that we know. You know,
I think that was a very special episode.
You know how they used to do that
with sitcoms? A very special episode.
They would always take on
like pregnancy, abortion, uh,
racism or something like that.
And then they would go right back to
being in an all white show. You know,
that's how white people cared in the 80s.
That's how we did it.
We didn't have to do any more than that.
That's all that there was.
Um,
so whenever I Kelly Olynyk Jesus Christ,
so I guess he's not going to do shit in
this series until then unless we get it
to game seven.
Um,
Celtics got the number one pick.
I mean,
it's just all that's all we got.
All we got to do now is just
wait until the Bron gets old.
And uh,
I actually hate the fucking warriors so
much that I don't care if they see if,
if the fucking Cavaliers sweep the Celtics
because I want them nice and rested
when they play those
fucking dirt bags out there.
Who's that other guy that got on the
tee where he j e you go to garden and he
jumps up to take a jump shot
and he kicked you in the balls.
He's kicked like half
the league and the balls.
I'm going to buy a half the league.
I mean like three or four different guys.
After a while it's like,
dude, that's you move.
Yeah.
I love all of ESPN.
Went to him to ask them if they thought
that fucking dead fucking Nazi Guard
House fucking guy that got there.
Yeah.
You know,
asked him if he thought he was dirty.
The Guy who accidentally
kicks people in the balls.
Yeah.
Do you think his teammates dirty?
I One?
Would you rather have you just have a
twisted ankles or rev your fucking balls
separated for the next nine years?
MMM.
Anyways, I don't know why. I don't know
why Chris Paul couldn't go to the Lakers,
but Kevin Duran could go to the,
to the fucking
the warriors and now that,
now that the worries are filthy as shit,
they took Leonard out of the
series. It's just, it's a joke.
Yeah.
I would rather watch the real housewives
in the western conference finals in the
NBA. Um, so anyways,
enough about that shit.
MMM.
Type in my password here, dude. What the
fuck's going on with the auto centers?
When are they going to start
behaving like the Ottawa senators?
I don't get what's going on here.
You know,
I still think the penguins are
going to beat him every time.
Like the penguins get the fucking shit
kicked out of him. Then what happens?
They come back, they give you
the old right there, Fred.
And they fucking, when the,
uh, they win the series, um,
I still think that they're going
to take the whole thing. Um,
yeah.
Now here's something I wanted to
talk to you guys about. Like the,
I just flew up here to fucking Winnipeg
and I don't know what happened,
but the fucking level of animal that
was on my flight to this guy next to me,
you know,
I told you I've right up front.
Yeah,
I haven't call it first class.
It's just human class.
They treat you like a human being.
That's all that happens upfront.
If you ever wanted, they don't smash you
all on the back and all that shit. Right.
So I'm waiting to get on. Right. So
they had people with wheelchairs,
they get on first and you know,
fucking people with kids. If
you're in the military, you know,
if you're wearing a red shirt, they
got like a bunch of things, right?
So people were sitting in first
class to getting all huffy going,
when's first class going to board,
right?
Yeah.
You know that white guy with the loafers
and no socks like that fucking energy.
Right?
So we're going to get on
in this fucking fat fuck,
you know, and his 20s just
completely blown out. Body,
big giant fat boys. I'm a polywood
producer. Fucking glasses,
stupid hat wearing sweatpants
and some big comfy fucking shirt.
You know, just giving into
the fact that's why he's fat.
All these fat people that
wear comfortable clothes,
you're going to be fat forever cause you,
cause you never,
you're not uncomfortable.
You got to keep the clothes that
you had when you were that weight.
You don't go to the fucking dry cleaner
or go to the Goddamn Nike store and buy
yourself a giant fucking sleeping
bag would draw strings on it.
Cause you're never gonna really feel how
fat you are until you don't go to get
on a fucking airplane.
Right?
Yeah.
So I'm, so this guy is trying to
cut the fucking line, right. And uh,
you know, I sort of box him out and uh,
they scanned my thing and I get to go to
get on the flight and just fucking fat.
Fuck comes down the thing and he
literally, he gets on the plane, he goes,
where am I sitting up front.
Okay.
Like really like,
like weird.
Like you can't just look gates and
lady like looks at the ticket and he's
fucking sitting right next to me.
So I'm putting my shit in the overhead
compartment. It's goes shoes way.
They fucking goes to brush
right by me. I said, hey buddy,
I go watch out from my bag.
And he's like, oh sorry.
He kind of backed back out again. You
know, he wasn't gonna hit my bank.
I just don't like how he fucking brushed
right by me. Right. So he sits down,
right. Giant fucking snowman
looking Douche bag. Right.
Sits down and he's so fat.
I'm in first class,
he's still spilling into my seat fucking
elbow in me and all that stuff. Yeah.
Shit. It's just like, this is not
what I'm spending my sky miles on,
you know. So, um, the lady,
the stewardess comes over, she goes, you
know, can get you guys something to drink,
right? I order a drink and the guy goes
of kind of a blanket. They go, she goes,
yes. So when she comes up with a
blanket and she holds it out to him,
he just fucking rips it out of
her hand and like open it up.
And just the way he was so choppy and like
aggressive yet couldn't find his seat.
I was like, this guy, I don't know what
this is. I don't know what the fuck this,
this, this guy on drugs. Is
He autistic? Is it Asperger?
I don't fucking know cause I don't really
know what the symptoms of any of that
shit is. You know, I saw the
rain man and uh, you know,
I dunno what else I fucking went on
podcasts on one time with somebody.
That aspect I can't fucking tell. I just
don't know that they act a little off.
All right. And I'm not going
to be yet another douche bag.
Who doesn't have a psychology degree,
let alone practicing that profession
to start analyzing somebody's mental
situations. So then he
fucking sits there. Okay.
A rips the blanket open cause somehow
this tub of shit is going to get fucking
cold and uh, he starts doing the, uh,
what's that thing when you restless legs
syndrome except his leg weighs as much
as my entire body.
So it's like actually shaking the plane
and I fortunately was a red eye on my
God, you know, let this
fucking guy just go to sleep.
But then is he going to have sleep apnea?
I don't know what, long story short,
we finally ended up, I
connected in Minneapolis. Okay.
And I,
when I got up I deliberately stood in
the way where he couldn't get out of his
seat cause I knew he was going to brush
by me once again and be fucking rude,
whatever.
Fuck his deal is.
So I passive aggressively stand there.
So I get off the plan, my grade,
I don't have to fucking deal
with this guy anymore. Right.
So I get off the plane and as I'm standing
there trying to figure out where my
connecting flight
gate is,
this fucking jerk off comes walking
off the plane and he still wearing the
blanket. He's got that wrapped
around them. Oh, by the
way, it was also of course,
wearing sandals, you know,
like all animals do. They just,
they have to have their feet
out. You know, like animals,
animals are all barefoot.
They don't have shoes,
right?
So these guys have sandals cause
they're half an animal, like,
you know what I mean?
If you're in a hot climate or you
fucking at the beach or whatever,
going down to the pool, the spa
that load that sandals. Anyways,
so he comes walking off the plane
and then just walks up to the,
you know,
those,
those little fucking cars that they
drive fat people around and old people,
blind people and stuff, you know. And uh,
he walks up to one of those guys
that goes, excuse me, sir. He goes,
what do I do for the next five hours?
Why away from my flight?
And that's what I was like, all right,
this guy's, this guy's fucked up.
The guy's like, ah, as a food court.
So then he walks up to the ticket lady.
Now I'm just standing there watching him
cause I got enough time cause now it's
entertaining.
Watching him meet people and watching
them doing the math on their face,
you know, is this, you see it on their
face like what the fuck am I dealing with?
So he talks to the ticket agent,
freaks her out,
then comes walking back and he walks up
to the car and he just goes, he goes,
sir,
where you taking me
and you pop psychologist. The guy finally
just goes, there's a food court down.
Then they just wandered off,
still wearing the blanket.
Now my buddy that I'm
working with this week,
he was trying to say that he
thought the guy was on pills.
I have no idea what the fuck it was.
But uh, it was hilarious. But anyways,
the level of fucking animal,
so that guy was there.
There was another guy in my flight,
he was wearing Pajama Pot Pajama bottoms
and he had a neck pillow, neck, pillow.
I mean,
I didn't even know where to go from there.
There was another guy who had the worst
hat I've ever seen and he was carrying a
hard shell case for the hat.
You know what I mean?
Well maybe that was his good hat.
He was wearing his bad hat on the
flight. I Dunno. It's like, wait,
what are you running for president in
1905 and some shit like you ride on a
goddamned who has a fucking hat box?
Kind of a man is a hatbox.
It was a solid plastic one, like, like a
snare drum case. But as for a fucking hat.
Um,
so for whatever reason I get here to the
hotel and I'm reading about this plane
Crash Air Canada flight six 24
they say the timeline of the crash,
right?
10 Oh five,
the plane leaves 10 56 Air
Canada that tells flight crew,
uh,
than an Air Canada flight had landed
on how effects runway oh five.
After a missed approach due to
insufficient visibility because of weather
conditions,
controller tells the crew to hold at 9,000
feet, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. Right? The fucking crew asked
to confirm to the Iran setting.
Five controller says that run four,
they'll eventually be on five.
They remain on for long story short,
this fucking guy flying this thing,
he ends up hitting like a snowbank.
Some lights,
he's fucking hit and shit off the plane.
They go slide down the runway
and they come to a stop.
Says aircraft comes to arrest about
1900 feet beyond the threshold.
Okay. This is like how scary this was. Um,
captain disconnects the autopilot
and plane makes automated calls.
There are hundreds and then 50 feet above
the land cope copilot says to pull up,
uh,
the AC, the Air Canada's six 24
Sevres in electric power line.
Cutting power to the airport terminal
captain advances thrust levers to the
takeoff goal around and pulls side.
Stick to the full nose up position.
A left main tire hits an approach like
861 feet from the runway threshold,
the main landing gear after lower fuselage
and left engine cowlings strike the
snow covered ground on an embankment
sloping towards the runway.
The plane strikes the localizer antenna,
um,
and continues airborne before striking
the ground twice more and sliding along
the runway.
This is what people are dealing with.
You guys ever see at Louis CK episode
where they were coming in for landing.
Everyone's screaming bloody murder.
That's what I picture and I picture Louis
on this flight for whatever reason. Um,
aircraft comes to arrest 1900 feet
beyond the threshold is completely lost.
Power Tower control acts activates
crash alarm as passengers.
Complete evacuation firefighters
arrived at the accident site.
Now listen to this.
Listen to this.
This is at 1236 when the
firefighters show up.
This is what they see when the
passengers are out on the runway.
Now this was a fucking snow storm
that they flew into passengers.
Many wearing open toed shoes,
shorts and tee shirts and carrying
baggage is baggage are grouped about 200
meters behind the aircraft
and frigid temperatures.
Occupants with most severe injuries
sit in the emergency vehicles. I mean,
kind of a fucking asshole gets on a god.
They have flight in the middle of a snow
storm wearing open toed fucking shoes,
sandals, shorts. You know,
next time I get on a flight and I see
those people getting on, I'll, I'll,
I'm going to be thinking as we
go down in the fucking Himalayas,
he's going to be the first
people to get eaten, you know?
Or are they going to be the first
people that you're going to have to kill
because they're going to be fighting
you for your fucking shoes. Um,
okay.
I don't even know what the
point of all of that was. All.
I'm just saying it's just the level of
animal that is at the fucking airport.
And you know what's funny too,
like it's just a way,
when you're walking through an
airport you can't really see,
you don't really see it. You know,
like the demographic that you're in,
you don't see it until
you get to your gate. Like
I didn't get the level of animal that
was going to fucking Winnipeg until I got
to the gate that was flying to Winnipeg
because it's like, you know what I mean?
It's like, it's like a,
it's like a mixed drink.
He can't taste the fucking alcohol.
Right. But then when you get to the gate,
when you get to your gate,
wherever the fuck you going,
barring a few tourists
who just going to visit,
that is a straight shot of what the fuck
you're, you're about ready to walk into
Pajama bottoms with a neck pillow.
MMM.
It's like, whenever I'm in New
York and I, I'm going to La,
it's like you look at
the Er at the airports,
like these people all look
like New Yorkers and then
all of a sudden you get to
the gate that's going to La and you
see the chick with the botox. You know,
you see the guy with the fake Tan,
you start seeing the god of your way
of dressing. It's like, all right,
these a la people, you know, and then
all of a sudden when you get off in la,
they totally blend in with people
at the fucking airport. I Dunno,
I always found that interesting. Well,
good built because we didn't, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Hang on a second. Let me,
let me read some advertising
here for this week and uh Oh,
by the way,
then I,
yeah,
I don't know.
Am I going to talk about this first
before I go into the advertising?
What's better? I'll come out of it and
talk about it. All right. Lift everybody.
L Y F, t. Uh,
when you drive for the
right ride sharing app,
every trip can feel like a
walk in the park. With Lyft,
you can pick your own hours
and work when you want.
Lift can make driving the
best job in the world.
Lyft is the ride sharing company
that believes in treating Pete.
It's people better lift believes that p
being a ride sharing drivers should be
fun if you're having a good time.
So the passengers,
if you're choosing a ride sharing
company to drive for, sorry,
is the drive for go with the company
that treats you better. Lift.
This is all shade right here.
Lift being all shady.
With Uber.
Lyft offers APP tipping.
When you drive for lip lift,
you keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $150 million
in since the feature was introduced.
Express pay lets drivers
get paid almost instantly.
Instead of waiting for weeks.
Live tizzies and taken the guesswork
out of pickups. The new app,
the new amp device uses color coding
to help passages find their driving's
drivers. You can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips.
Want to make more money,
drive more.
It's been never been easier to give
yourself a raise. It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers being happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft
rides get a perfect five star rating.
So join the ride sharing company that
believes in treating people better.
Go to lift.com/burger today and you
can get a $500 new driver bonus.
$500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com l y f t.com.
Limited time only terms apply.
Oh good.
There's only two. Oh, this is great
movement. You guys. No movement.
Do you feel, I dunno, they,
they reinvented the watch business by
selling direct to you with over one on 1
million watches sold today.
I just can't fucking read today.
While they did it again,
except this time was sunglasses.
They're going to start selling
amber vision. Oh my God,
everything is so much crisper and clearer.
Uh,
they were tired of having
to pay for cheaply,
made throwaway shades or
overpriced designer sunglasses.
So they said, fuck it.
We'll make our own starting
at just 70 bucks. Uh,
talk about your personal experience
with the new pair of sunglasses,
which pair you have,
how they look slash feel,
what you enjoy most about it,
how people ask you about it.
What do you want to know, where you
purchased and how much does it cost?
All right. None of that
happened. I even know you are.
This is the first I'm hearing you guys
make sunglasses. So none of that happened.
But it does seem to get a lot of attention
out there on the streets if you start
wearing them. Um, so be careful. If
you're not looking for attention,
I wouldn't get these fucking sunglasses.
That's incredible. We're going,
everything that had happened would
have happened if I got him. You know,
people would want to know about it.
Hey Man, what'd you get? Those glasses?
No.
Want to know about those glasses? Where'd
you buy? What'd you purchase them?
How much they cost? Talk
about em. Talk about movement.
Ver varied selection
and styles of finding.
The perfect pair is risk free with free
shipping and free returns. All right?
Evidently they have a
selection, sunglasses, and a,
you pick the one that looks the best
on you. Stupid head. And uh, you know,
there's no risk in that. No one's
going to be watching. You should do it.
Hubway movement sunglasses started
just $70 with the option to upgrade to
polarized. Oh, is that where
no one can see your eyes?
Is that what you're polarized?
Mean, like a riverboat gambling?
Then write those overpriced designer
brands will run you up to $200.
These are high quality premium
acetate frames. A, C, e, t,
t, e, no cheap plastic here.
You got to have these. They have lots of
styles to choose from. Classy, trendy,
round aviator mirrored
polarized for him or her.
You're sure to find the perfect pair.
Call to action.
Parenthesis must read.
Get 50% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to
movement.com/burr you know,
movement for how they look.
Revolutionize the watch industry. Now's
the time to check out their sunglasses.
Go to a movement,
watches.com mvmt.com/burr
join the goddamn movement.
MMM Wow.
Like I said, I hate doing fucking
podcast on days that I travel.
MMM.
What am I up to here? All right,
let's talk about it. Everybody. Um,
rest in peace. Chris Cornell. Holy Shit.
Unbelievable man.
It's one of the best fucking
singers in rock history.
And, um, I hope with this saying, I mean,
I guess if you die you die.
But I just, I don't know.
I hope they're not going to do
all a whole bunch of, you know,
you know, they do that. They got
to kill you again after you die.
MMM.
Jesus Christ. What a fucking band.
What a, what an artist. What,
uh, just the music just
holds up.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of music that I listened
to when I went back. You know,
the shit that I used to listen to
as a kid. I was like, oh my God,
this is horrible.
This is the second Barisone I still
listen to it because of the, you know,
reminds me of a time in my life.
But when I come up to the red light,
I got to turn it down. Nothing.
Chris Cornell over did.
Did you have to turn down?
You could,
you could fucking have it
cranked and never be embarrassed.
I'm such a huge, huge
fucking loss. And once again,
someone I should have gone to see,
never did too busy doing
this comedy fucking thing.
I was going to go see temple of the dog
and I had some other show I couldn't go.
I think Dean del Ray had tickets
to that. He was like, dude,
it was fucking unbelievable.
And um,
and it's just fucking awful. Just awful.
I was a huge fan of that band. And, uh,
so now what happens?
I know they're in the middle of a tour,
you know,
you don't, what they do now is
they just find some fucking guy on,
on the Internet that does
like an impression of them
and then all of a sudden
the guy has to fucking go up there
and be like a rock star. Like I, I,
I've never seen a band like that.
I've never gone to see a band like that,
although I heard the guy from Alison
chains fucking murders it. So who knows?
Um,
I dunno,
how do you get out of this?
See,
that's why I fucking hate
talking about sad shit like that.
MMM.
Somewhere in all of that,
I saw a fucking way out of this and
now I don't know what the fuck it is.
So anyways, uh, plowing ahead,
fucking plowing ahead. He, oh, I
know what to say. You know what?
I went back and I downloaded
skid row's slave to the grind
and that album, that album marked
the end of my musical youth,
that album came out in like the summer
of [inaudible] 91 and then in September
fucking,
you know,
all of a sudden Nirvana's album
came out and then that was just, it.
All of my band's got
wiped the fuck off at MTV,
you know? And, um,
so I went back and I downloaded a slave
to the grind monkey business and all
that, which then maybe go watch, uh,
you know, a bunch of skid row fucking
videos and there's a video, man, I,
you gotta see this shit.
It's from 1991,
I believe.
91 or 92.
It's skid row on SNL and
Sebastian Bach in the whole band,
just fucking murdering
monkey business. And I don't know,
to me that was like the, for me,
I just feel like I'm doing it now.
I've said it so much that
I actually say for me now,
I say for me and to me
because I keep doing it.
It's like when I met Mandy, I used to
make fun of this guy who said, yeah,
you liked did that, you liked
it, did that. And I still,
I kept and we just kept
doing it to each other.
And I was in a meeting one time pitching
his show and I was talking about a
comic that I liked and I said, yeah, I saw
the special. Yeah, I liked it. Did that.
I went, oh my God. And it was actually
liked it and we started going like,
did it to make it even more ridiculous.
And I literally said like,
they did it and the, I saw the person's
face, like, look at me like, like,
does he have a stutter? I can't
put this guy on fucking camera. Um,
anyways,
so I'm watching this fucking video and,
and it was the end of like aggressive,
fun fucking bands.
Like they would just fucking kill it.
It just,
it,
they were like rock stars and they were
enjoying it before the grunge came in
and everyone saying, God,
I wish I was like, you
easily amused. I always hated that fucking
line. And you don't fucking know me.
You condescending cunt.
I'm not easily amused and I don't find
what the fuck you trying to suggest about
me even remotely amusing.
Can somebody please make a video of that
Kurt Cobain singing that line and then
you cut the joke. Peshy so what? I'm
like a clown. I like I amuse you.
MMM.
Anyways, yeah. And then all the sad
guys came in, Kurt Cobain fucking,
uh, uh, was the Pearl
Jam guy. Eddie vetter.
Okay.
That fucking interview that Kurt Loder
does with them and he's literally like,
he looks like superman sitting
next to fucking Kryptonite.
Like that's how much he's
like folded over himself.
Like he didn't want to
answer any of the questions.
Like it was literally having a
physical reaction to somebody,
ask him questions like,
Hey man,
you're selling a bunch of albums that's
gotta feel good. Right. And he was like,
Hey, it is, I don't even know how
to fucking, you know what I mean?
All of a sudden he had like the
fucking posture, Fiona Apple.
There were a bunch of fragile people,
but in the middle of all of that,
in the middle of all of that was fucking
Chris Cornell still belted out like a
fucking,
yeah.
I Dunno.
My version of what a rock star is,
didn't go out there wearing a granny
sweater trying to act like he was somebody
in the crowd. It's like, no, you're
better than me. Be better than me.
I don't want to see me up there.
Be a fucking God.
MMM.
I don't know.
And I just thought Chris Cornell had
the goods when it came to that and uh,
it made me go,
I don't know,
I just didn't listen to a lot of
music right around that, that era.
And I've always known it. I
make fun of Nevada. I know
there a great bandage. Shit.
I know they are. I just, it's just fun.
They're fun to make fun of
because everyone's always like,
and did that album came out,
I knew that music as I
knew it had now changed,
which is complete horseshit. There was
a few people that knew most of us did,
like, who's this new band? And then all
of a sudden it was this other new band.
And that was just like all of a sudden
MTV decided that they were going to just
like,
this was the new shit.
And they just started spooning it into
our mouths and we fucking hate it. I mean,
that's basically what happened.
I was more than willing
yeah.
To watch all those same bands
I had been listening to keep,
continue to put out albums.
I didn't have a fucking problem.
You know what it was MTV was done with me.
And uh,
that was the first time I really felt old.
I was 23 years old and I was just
like, yeah, that stayed. They don't,
I'm done as far in their head.
I'm already married with two fucking
kids and they can't squeeze a dime out of
my pockets, so fuck this guy. Right.
And then it was smashing Pumpkins,
you know,
I dunno.
But Soundgarden was always one where I
didn't have to make the leap of like,
okay, this is this new shit. I just
kind of sounds a little different.
Like I absolutely fucking love that
band and love all the odd time stuff.
I love all of this shit and it's just
a fucking shame. It's a fucking shame.
But you know something,
if you want to watch something uplifting,
I'm going to post. Um, skid
row was Sebastian Bach,
absolutely fucking murdering
monkey business. And uh,
I love to, in the end when he, he,
after you've just fucking destroys one
of the greatest live voices underrated of
all fucking time.
Then he was like funny in the end after
like doing those high fucking heavy
metals screams all the way
down to the growl and then
the end, he's just like, oh,
thank you very much.
He just feels like this weird voice.
Ah, it was awesome. So anyways, rest
in peace, Chris Cornell. And, um,
I dunno, I dunno what else to say. I'm
so fucking sick of having to say that,
but I guess that's a part of getting old.
Um,
which is something I had to actually
talk to you about that talk to you guys
about that.
You know,
like that thing where you just want
to be on to live to be a hundred.
It's like part of living to be 100 is
you're going to bury all your friends,
you know,
and if you're really start looking at
your friends and if you're remotely taken
care of yourself,
you know which ones are going to go,
I hate to say it,
but you do that fucking guy eating the
burgers and the fries and the fucking
just putting on another 10 every year.
Every year the Christmas sweater
gets a little bit bigger, right?
Yeah.
Till the next day you wandered around
ordering people around wearing the fucking
airplane blanket through the fucking
terminal area. Yeah. Like that guy,
that guy I saw that guy's
not gonna be around long.
It's not gonna be around long.
You know what I mean?
I think that restless leg
syndrome that he had going on,
that was his heart screaming for help.
You know,
I've given them enough chest pains.
He is not listening to me.
Can Somebody for the love of God slap
the fuck twinkie out of this guy's mouth
out. Jesus felt, why do you gotta
be me? All right. So anyways,
I got Winnipeg tonight than Saskatoon,
the Paris of the prairies.
And then I got fucking uh,
Regina and I would not do one vagina joke.
I did one of the podcast just cause
you know, you gotta do one taught city,
you have rip city,
you got the twin city and you
got to watch city and that's it.
So now it not that this is
going to be some nerdy shit.
This isn't even the podcast right
now. Here we go. Hang on one second.
Let me get a fucking map
of Canada map of can uh,
uh,
uh Oh.
Did I ever get the Edmonton fans and
shout out to sing the national anthem.
Oh, come on. Why does it
always go to Wikipedia? Now.
I don't need to know
what a map of Kennedy is.
I need to fucking see one map of Canada,
our home and native land tool head.
Uh
hmm.
[inaudible]. All right, here we go.
Visit page and I've got to go to the page
and now I've got to try and
make the fucking map bigger.
I want to see a map of Canada.
This is it. All right. Yeah, I have
been to with this fucking trip.
As far as the southern portion,
I think I've been to every major city.
I got Vancouver, Calgary,
Edmonton, Saskatoon,
Regina,
Winnipeg.
Yeah,
Toronto, Ottawa, Montreal.
Then I've been to like Monkton.
I Bet I went to the maritimes.
I came in with a fuck.
I went something to Nova Scotia, New
Brunswick. I know I went to New Brunswick,
maybe not Nova Scotia.
Um,
I dunno.
I've been to fucking hammered
town. I've been to London, Ontario.
I mean, I think yellow knife is
next. That's where I got to go next.
I should all start in Alaska.
I'll do something in the
Yukon territory with the FEC.
Same in that place up there.
I can't see. It's all blurry.
So say Whitesnake is that
where the bands from? I Dunno.
I'll put it together, but this
is, I'm not going to submit. Um,
this was the last province that I
needed to go on the southern southern
hemisphere. What the fuck is
it called? Saskatchewan. Yeah.
Had Saskatoon in my head. All
right. That was complete filler.
I don't know why I just did that.
That was your breakfast potatoes
here on the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. All right.
We're gonna play a little music here.
Obviously we do some sound garden
and then you can listen to some, uh,
another half hour of some greatest hits
from a Thursday gone by and another time
or a podcast on Monday. I don't know what
the fuck it is. Um, all right, that's it.
I will. You guys have a great weekend. You
can't, and I will talk to you on Monday.
And once again,
a rested pieces of great Christmas.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
hey, what's up? It's the
Monday morning podcast.
Hey, what's going on at this
bill for the Monday morning
podcast?
And this is the third attempt at trying
to be even remotely and musing on the
thing. It's like the thick time. I've
tried to start doing this podcast.
What's going on? It's Belper
doing the Monday morning podcast.
If you want to seize every God damn week,
every week, every Monday, and let this,
uh, Christmas for some shit. I don't
want to take a day off. All right?
And I worked for myself.
Why does cy uh, Bill Barr?
Yeah. Hey, what's going on? This just
go bro. It's going on and still birth.
Yeah. Isn't that exciting? Every Monday
I do a fucking podcast. All right.
What do you want from me? You
know, hey, what's going on?
She's still bar and uh,
this is not the Monday morning podcast.
Hey,
what's up man?
It's still fun and it is the Monday
morning podcast and I'm going to be
multitasking this week.
Hey, what's going on?
It is a dope burn and this is
the Monday morning podcast. Um,
welcome. Welcome. If you're new to it.
I do one of these every single Monday.
I answered questions.
People email me.
[inaudible] is that [inaudible] people
send me in there a underrated overrated
list. Things that they feel
are underrated, things that
they feel are overrated.
Hey, what's going on? This
is so far, and this is, uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
This is the official one.
You see? You see, that's what
I was trying to do last week.
That's what I was trying to do.
I was trying to slip in the
MP three of the week there.
That's what I was trying to do there. Did
you enjoy it? Was it a little bit long?
Did my edits sock?
I'm sure it did and I'm,
I'll get emails from people because
that's what the web is really all about.
It's not about connecting
with other people.
It's about having the ability to tell
somebody that they fucking suck when
they're just sitting there
in their underwear eating a
bowl of fucking we checks,
you know, that's how my day
starts. Every fucking day.
Every day I get up and a while.
I take my dog for a walk now, which
is fucking awesome. I do that.
But then, uh, wait a minute, don't I?
I probably do go on my space first.
That's how pathetic I am.
I will literally get on my space and a,
I checked out a couple emails,
a couple of comments on whatever
shows I've done something.
You saw me on some fucking
picture I put up in.
There's always somebody breaking
my balls over there. And uh,
that's what the Internet is.
That's what the Internet is.
It's a bunch of punk spirit able to
heckle people without being able to get
trashed back. You know,
but I'm guilty of it too.
So what the fuck am I going to
do? All right. It's bill bird,
some Monday morning podcast if you
didn't know that from the beginning. Uh,
the opening there,
that's a new thing I'm going to
try to be doing is a MP3 the week.
I don't know if I'm going to do it
every week cause I really, you know,
I already deal with all the
questions you guys send me,
which really krump clogs
up my email folders and uh,
but you know, every once in
a while, sorry, you know,
if you've got a cool idea,
send it in. If it's something I can use
on the podcast, I'll definitely do it.
But I gotta admit I'm kind of nervous
about getting a fucking, uh, a virus,
you know, listening to all that audio, you
know, you're not supposed to open shit,
so I don't want to, I don't
want to do that, you know,
so I don't even know where,
I just fucking told you there and I'm
sure there's people out there right now.
Oh, you're worried about
getting a virus open it all,
you OpenNotes somebody g mail.
Are you that fucking stupid?
That's another thing I like about the
Internet is when you've just asked people
for fucking help that nobody can, you
know, some people can help you out,
but so many people on the internet,
their way of helping you out is to give
you information while calling you a
fucking moron,
which is why this week on the
Monday morning part podcast,
if you are fans of this, you know
that I have douche bag of the week,
but there were so many douche bags
this week. I almost have to, I, I,
I almost was like con to the week.
I almost had to bump it up,
you know what I mean?
But I stopped short of that out of respect
for some of the female listeners out
there. So I'm going with Douche bags
of the week. That's plural. All right,
this is it. It's the last
week, if you, if you listened.
I did get a dog and a,
I've never had a dog before and I was
having issues because, uh, whatever,
listen to last week's podcast,
I don't have to fucking get into it,
but we had a specialist come over here
to find out what the dog's problem was.
And evidently it has
separation anxiety because, um,
it's a perfect fucking dog.
It doesn't launch after our other
dogs doesn't go at lunch after people.
It's fucking mellow. It just chills
out. But if you leave it alone,
it like freaks, you know, or if it
anticipates that you're leaving it alone,
it starts like shaking uncontrollably
and it starts drooling,
which are all signs, I guess,
of this separation anxiety.
So evidently it's this four week fucking
process that I have to go through.
But I totally love the dog now,
so I don't give a fuck.
I literally canceled gigs to make
sure this dog is cool. And, um,
it's,
it's a long story.
If you want to know what you gotta
do is basically what I've learned is,
is there's certain triggers that the dog
has that sets it off to freaking out.
Like you're grabbing your keys
and here's the sound of your keys.
Or maybe you turn the shower on,
or your girlfriend starts blow
drying her hair or whatever.
Just things like that starts at,
you know, starts looking at you,
and then you put your shoes on,
you put your coat on and all,
and all it associates that shit with is,
Oh fuck,
I'm being abandoned again. And
you know, I don't fucking know.
I don't write the books.
I don't have the ability to actually
know what a dog is thinking.
But I'm imagining,
considering that this dog was
just left by the La River,
can you believe that someone didn't
even bring it to the shelter?
They just opened their car
door or whatever and just
left it out there. You know,
like, I don't know what the fuck at
eight kills me, kills me every time.
I think that someone
would do that. But, um,
so I guess that that's where this
dog's mind goes mentally. So, uh,
we have to fucking deconditioned.
You've got to figure out what it's an,
the very first trigger is,
and then you work your way through all
of them and you just do one trigger,
like pick up your keys, sort of walk
around with them as you're given it.
This food. I don't even, I just
read the fucking book. It's,
it's a long goddamn process,
but I'm going to work through it.
So that's basically what you're supposed
to do in a nutshell. I'm really,
and you know what I mean?
Do you ever just read something on the
Internet and then you try to fucking talk
about it? Like, you know
what you're talking about?
That's what that last couple
of minutes was, but it's,
it's, you know, I'm fucking,
I'm, I'm learning about this
stuff and I'm gonna, you know,
I'm going to do what I gotta do,
but basically I have been
held captive with this dog.
I've been with this fucking
dog for the last, uh,
five days in a row other than when I go
out to do sets. But then my girls here,
when we just make sure
we don't leave it alone,
so it doesn't freak out as we
learn how to diffuse. It's problem.
Okay.
So last week I was asking people if they
have any ideas cause I went to put the
thing in a cage, which was a stupid
fucking thing to do. I just didn't,
I was ignorant. I didn't know. I
didn't know what the dog's problem was.
I didn't know how to introduce a cage to
a dog who's gone through the stuff that
my dog's gone through. So, you
know, I made a rookie mistake,
so I was reaching out to
my podcast listeners and a,
these are some of the
emails. I got a bill. Uh,
I've always been in a household with
dogs since I was born and I've never had
any of those fucking small female
dogs like a Chihuahua. I mean,
I had big male dogs, German shepherds,
Husky labs, that type of stuff.
And uh, one of my dogs has broken
out of his cage before. However,
you must not know how to
train a dog because mine
never fucked up the house even
when he was young.
Dogs are so rowdy and hard to
handle when they are young,
they are hyper and they need
lots of attention. By the way,
you really shouldn't have a dog if
someone can't be home with it most of the
day. Now, I don't know about you
guys. I'm stopping halfway through,
but that was just packed with
information that I didn't know. Really.
I shouldn't have a dog if someone
can't be home with it most of the day.
I had no idea. You know, I
thought I could just get a dog,
stick them on the roof of my fucking
apartment and leave for seven days.
I figured maybe it'll rain,
you know, and they don't,
don't they store water in their
bodies like fucking camels.
I have no idea what a fucking douchebag.
He's already a Douche bag.
And then he has the balls,
the fucking ego wrapped around his balls
to write another paragraph of obvious
shit. Here we go. Everybody. Here we go.
I've you got a three year olds out there.
Maybe they want to listen to the rest of
this for this fucking information here.
Here's what this fucking Einstein says.
The residence,
you have to give it affection.
It's like a baby.
She except you don't have to send it to
college. Now. He didn't say that part.
All right. Uh, she just wants attention.
She needs to be walked
and petted and played with
everyday. That's right. Petted.
This is the guy that thinks
I'm a fucking morning. Um,
how often do you walk her and
pet her and pet her daily?
Were you drunk when you take this? You
already said pet aid in the other thing.
Anyways, he says, guess what? You do
have to fucking build up the trust of,
or the dog isn't going to obey you
as that.
That right there in a nutshell is how
people give advice on the Internet.
Guess what?
Hey fuck head like that whole vibe.
It just blows my mind why someone
can't be like, oh, hey, I got a dog.
This is the stuff I went through
and this is kind of what I tried.
Hope it works every he's got,
everybody's got, not everybody,
but so many people came at me like I
couldn't believe it. So anyways, he says,
guess worth.
You do have to fucking build up trust
or the dog isn't going to obey you.
Really, really? I had no idea.
I thought I was like fucking Tarzan.
I could just start communicating on a
fucking doctor Doolittle. What an asshole.
Your asshole Douche bag and con to the
week and I haven't even finished your
fucking email. All right,
I'm continuing. Um,
all right. What the fuck? Why
can't we get through this sentence?
Guess what your blah, blah, blah.
And she's going to find every way she can
to break loose when she's confined and
you're not home.
My lab is 13 years old,
but he still needs to
play and be petted it.
Is it petted? It needs
to be pet you dumb. Fuck.
That's not even a word. Hey
fuck head. Now I'm doing it.
I'm just pissed because you
coming at me like this. You can't.
I just asked you for advice,
you know,
thank God you don't teach kids anyways.
Uh,
if yours is whimpering at night,
it's most likely she didn't get
much interaction. Feels lonely.
Three e's and fields. By the way, I
don't think you should have a dog bill.
Really? I don't think you should have a
computer. What do you think about that?
How about that? Fuck head. I don't
think you should have a queue.
You shove a fucking computer screen,
but not a keyboard.
Maybe a secretary. I learned
nothing in that. All right.
First of all,
Douche bag of the week.
Why would you think that you could even
begin to analyze what is wrong with this
dog without ever meeting it?
You're basically super imposing the
dogs you had in your life over this dog.
Did any of the dogs you have get left by
a fucking river for God knows how many
fucking days now you know it was just
going to make it up. Well, yes judge.
My Labrador was loved by a phone.
Ah. Do dogs need attention?
Do you understand? I mean,
I guess because I didn't explain it.
You've got to understand,
I've been giving this dog
so much attention. It's,
it's affecting my relationship
with my girlfriend,
okay? She has all she can do
to get me to cuddle with her,
but I have literally been late.
I can't walk to the fridge without laying
down on the floor with that fucking
dog and telling them how awesome it
is for like 20 minutes every time.
I'm not getting anything done a right?
You fucking moron. I've had dogs.
I also grew up with dogs. I was
just asking for help. All right?
You can't stop acting like everyone in my
family, Jesus Christ. You know what? I,
I feel so much better about my family.
Some of these fucking emails.
I didn't want it. I don't want
to be angry. Look at this.
What this is doing to me.
All right, here's the second douche
bag of the week. He'll ever contests.
Which one of these two people do you
think is a bigger douche bag this week or
are they both? Cons. All right, here we
go. There's a second email. First off,
I really enjoy your comedy and your
Monday morning podcast when you don't tart
out and post it on time.
That part doesn't even make sense.
So you enjoy it.
When I don't tart out and post
it on time, I don't get the, Oh,
when I don't tart out, when I'm not a
moron, and I posted it on time. Okay,
maybe that's me. All right, second.
So he starts off nice or she,
I don't even know the fuck wrote this
second, try not using a fucking cage
addenda.
I swear to God and adult wrote their
second try not using a fucking cage,
a Duh.
Now,
why would you think the reader at
this point would remotely give off?
You could be telling me how to
win $1 million in this paragraph.
The second you come at me,
this condescendingly I'm not,
I don't give a fuck what you have to say,
but for the sake of my listeners,
I'm going to read the rest of
this. All right? You fucking,
I need a new cord for Conti.
There's so many cons this week.
All right, let's start over
again with that sentence. Second,
try not using a fucking cage.
A De,
as long as you keep small objects in
and your trash away from the dogs reach,
you can get the dog to pass out. Most
of the time you're away. Once again,
here's a guy,
has no idea what I'm dealing with,
and he completely writes off cages.
You know,
all these people you see at the airport
where the dogs in one of those fucking
cages and they don't have a problem with
it because they introduced the cage in
a proper way rather than the stupid way
that I did it at the pet store where I
tried to figure out if the dog could fit
into it by pushing it by headfirst as
I'm pushing its ass as it's using all
its pit bull muscle on the linoleum to be
like, Eh, don't feel like going
in there. You know, whatever.
I'm not good with spatial relations.
I did what I had to do. Um,
okay, let's continue. Um, as we,
the first week of trying to
figure out the new section,
who's a bigger Douche bag? All right.
Let me read the rest of this year.
I'm finding a proper dog toy is necessary
but avoid anything that can be eaten
and salivated on
Dash Rawhides.
Now there's almost some information so I
know I don't need raw hides and I don't
know why he's a, he hasn't really told
me why, but I guess I just avoid those.
Um, this is like getting sex
education in like the forties,
you know when no one could fucking talk
about it. This is brutal. All right.
Instead of all that time you wasted
teaching the dog to be comfortable in an
incompatible place, an uncomfortable
place. He's talking about the cage.
You could have been teaching
it to behave in the household.
Really? Oh, I had no idea.
It's not like I walked in into the fucking
apartment and just shoved it into a
cage. You fucking idiot. I had it on the
leash. I walked at all around the house.
Everything was going great, everything
was going great, and then it had some bad,
had bad experiences with the cages,
and then it won't go in the room where
the cage was because it had a bad
experience in there. Jesus, fuck, I
don't, I'm sick of these dog whisperer.
People Watch fucking 10 episodes
and then they think they can,
they can like fucking put their
hand on top of your dog and cure it.
I don't know,
not that you care,
but my friend of 10 years has had
two pit bulls in a house area,
smaller than my one bedroom apartment
and it doesn't destroy anything that you
don't allow it to destroy for every
failed attempt of taking a dog in a dog,
there is a flunky of an owner. Evidently
that's me. You don't even have kids.
You can definitely do this bill.
See that's positive.
Have patients and understanding and that
dog will give you unconditional love
for many years. All right.
You know this guy is like,
this is like a battered wife fucking
email. He starts off nice. Sucks me in.
First off, I really enjoy your comedy
Monday morning podcast. I'm like, yeah,
you have really, as I'm sticking my chin
out, then he gives me a fucking uppercut.
Try not use in a fucking cage. Uh
Duh. Right. And then he trashes me,
basically eludes to the fact that I'm a
flunky, maybe a flunky owner. I Dunno.
And then they start stroking my head
when I, and I'm like, you know what?
I'm out of this relationship.
I'm going back home to my father.
I don't need this anymore.
And then he says,
now they'll have patients and
understanding the dark, you know,
you're beautiful and
you're little Dickie shorts
anyways. You know something, you animal
lovers, you're out of your fucking minds.
That's all I can say.
You got more goddamn passion for animals
than you do for losing your fucking
conveniences in this country.
You know what I mean?
They'll fucking stand there and continue
to pay $15 for their first fucking bag.
Even though the price
of gas has come down.
You can never get them to sign a
fucking petition. But Jesus Christ,
if somebody throws an errant frisbee and
it hits a fucking shower in the side of
his fucking leg, though, we hate,
there'll be fucking making soccer.
We have people with signs.
If I have,
if somebody from the goddamn animal
shelter ever heard my last podcast,
I probably have protestors outside
my next funnybone Gig. So anyways,
uh,
I want to thank everyone who actually
sent me advice trying to help me out.
Okay. I'm not a bad dog owner. Okay.
I just didn't understand what the dog was
going through. Okay. And it's, you know,
it's had to,
it had three really traumatic events
since I've had it just out of my own
ignorance.
Okay.
I put it in two different cages because
I didn't understand why it was clogging
up my apartment. I just thought it
was doing what dogs do, you know.
And once again,
I didn't fucking decide to get a dog.
My girlfriend just brought this thing
home. So we add our lives to lead.
So that was a horrific experience.
And one day when we left,
we love to do it or our balcony open.
And this kills me to say this.
It walked out on the balcony and the wind
blew the doors shut and was stuck out
there for like 40 minutes.
And when we got there,
it was standing there trembling and
drew, it was fucking, it was horrific.
And uh, I, I, you know, I felt
like I didn't deserve a dog.
Uh, so since then, no,
I take it for hikes every day just
to make you fucking dog lovers relax.
Okay. I swear to God. All right.
I just watched, I was, you know,
I'm actually doing this,
this podcast by the way,
on a Sunday evening here
because I want to make sure I,
I was able to edit that thing on
the front and do everything right.
So people in the east coast wouldn't
have to wait till the end of the fucking
day to listen to this
thing. But, um, you know,
I want to go play drums. I wanted to
play drums for three fucking days,
but I refuse to leave this dog alone.
I refused for this dog to have another
bad experience due to me on my watch.
So all you guys can relax and
if you want to give me advice,
give me advice. But I don't need
advice that begins with hey shit,
Dick or whatever that you know, cause
that really is, you can tell it.
All it does is fucking annoying me, you
know, and I combined that I can, you know,
I thought I had a great week. You
know, I gave you guys a podcast.
I put a new video up on my myspace
page and on my youtube page,
by the way,
which I don't have the fucking name for,
I forget the name of it,
but a, I put it up there.
I put up like fucking 30 new photos.
What else did I do?
So that was a video.
I gave you a podcast,
I gave you new pictures and I've been
pulled. I blogged all week for the NHL.
You know, by the way, congratulations
to the Carolina hurricanes.
He has sons of bitches a
best for checking. I've,
I've seen on a hockey team and a
long fucking time. You guys were,
you were phenomenal.
You deserve to wear that and a
good lucks against the penguins.
You sons of bitches and anybody
who took my blog seriously,
uh, you can go fuck yourself because, uh,
it says in the thing that I'm a comedian.
So if you take my joke seriously, I,
I can't, I can't help you. You know,
you know what I mean?
I,
I'm trying to fucking come up
with an analogy here. You know,
I don't expect the Weatherman to be funny,
you know,
and I don't expect the comedian
to be seriously serious.
So if they write something fucked
up that obviously the joking,
so all those references I made
you guys not having shoes and
in play and washboards and tubs in
the stands and fucking, you know,
not being real hockey fans
cause you're from down south.
If you took any of that seriously,
then you really are the moron that I
was jokingly saying that you were. Okay.
You know why I was referring to you
as the Hartford whalers. All right.
I was having fun. I was
just talking shit. You know,
unless I say it about Montreal Canadien
fans, that's the only time I mean it,
you know,
but even then I'll give up.
They get a beautiful city with gorgeous
women. Um, all right, so there you go.
So onto the podcast here and I'm,
I'm basically going to be reading a
bunch of shit that I read last week but
wasn't able to, uh, to update and
uh,
where the fuck am I? Uh, what are we
going to do here? What am I get to? Uh,
some of the things that I asked am
I my podcast a couple of weeks ago,
I had mentioned a couple
of weeks ago that I was a,
I was flying from New York to a back out
here to la at the height of the swine
flu epidemic.
No, but that one, you know,
the devastation, bring out your dead,
you know, nothing fucking happened.
But anyways, I get on the plane or
I'm waiting to get on the plane.
I sit in the terminal and I noticed that,
you know,
there's a couple of hundred people
there waiting to get on the plane and 15
people are wearing those surgical masks
and all 15 were Asian and there was no,
nobody else have any race was wearing
the mask. So I was like, what the fuck?
Why are they the only ones wearing mass?
And somebody actually sent me a,
an interesting observation, I don't know
if this is true or not, but they said,
hey bill, you asked about the agents
wearing the mass. I may have an answer.
As person says,
I was over in Japan last year and notice
that I would see people wearing those
masks everywhere I went.
So I asked somebody in mind who lives
there and he said that because everyone is
so jam packed up to their eyeballs
and people basically they're in close
proximity. Uh, they were there,
they were mess because uh,
they wear them. Um, what does
it say? I just lost my place.
They wear them even when
they just have a cold.
I'm assuming it's just a way
of life to where the mass,
when you're sick or something,
hope this helps.
So I guess over there everybody is
so jam packed and I imagine a Co uh,
the common cold would
spread like wildfire.
So they put those things on. I, I,
I guess that kind of makes sense.
What does that mean?
All 15 of them has had the common
cold or they all had the bird flu,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
Or maybe they're more educated.
Evidently their is better over this
somehow what happened to America,
you know what I mean? We were
the shit, we still are the shit.
We're just a bunch of fucking people now
sitting around in cubicles, you know.
Do you guys see some of the pictures of
the great American cars that I put up
there? Just, you know, I only put up like
three. I want to put up a bunch more. But,
uh, that period, man, I'm
telling you from the 1940s,
right through the 60s,
you know,
where it was just the heyday of American
cars and the steel industry and all
that type of shit. We had a
fuck what happened. You know,
what happened at where we can't, we
don't make the best cell phone. We would,
that should really bother
us, shouldn't it? Whatever.
This fucking, I don't know. It's
really bug. It's really bothering me.
So I don't know. I really don't
have anything to say about it.
But if you listen to these last fucking,
if you listened to that pathetic
attempt at social commentary,
maybe you understand why we can't make
a good cell phone or the best one out
there. And speaking of that, um,
let's talk about computer stuff.
You know, this is the new segment.
I wish I had a little bit of
theme music out there. You know,
if somebody could write me some,
uh, you're going to learn something,
theme music and send it as an MP three.
I'll play it for this part because
this is a new segment here where, um,
you guys are basically teaching me
how not to be a moron with my, uh,
with my computer. And
um, this is something,
last weekend I was bitching about how
people always send me these emails and the
font is really small and hour.
I already suck at reading out
loud if you haven't noticed yet.
So I was wishing that people would
send it bigger. So someone goes,
well actually this is what you can do
if somebody sends us an email and you
can't really read it
because the fonts too small,
all you have to do is hit the
apple command button and the uh,
the plus side, like you know, two
plus two and you can make the,
you can make the font get bigger or the
apple and the minus sign and you can
make it get smaller and it even
works on the Internet, you know,
for like old people you know, that are
trying to find tube eight, you know,
trying to find a two
girls one cup and Kurt,
you want to show [inaudible]
so they hit apple fucking plus.
Wow. How big old people's
keyboards you ever seen that?
Like you ever see like old people's
phones, you ever seen that?
And like the fucking,
it's like literally the number pad is
as big as like a toddler's hopscotch.
Fucking bored. You know, you
have a see some shit like that.
It just really scares you.
You know,
dying doesn't really scare me
because I really have this belief.
Like I really believe in that whole thing
that like death is a release and uh,
I'm looking forward to becoming
a fossil fuel. You know, like, I,
I don't really need to continue this,
you know, I just, you
know, I think, you know,
live in light live. If you
live a full life, that's
enough. That should be enough.
And then I, then I should
just become a, yeah. Fuel.
Can't think of anything. I don't know.
Moon, dust, whatever the fuck do you know,
just become part of some shit
that other things that are alive.
Look at what do I got to keep living.
Do you realize the fucking how? Uh,
Ego maniacal that is,
yeah.
To feel that you're like God like that
you just continue living in this other
state. I don't understand that.
It's really hard to see that,
that or you just can't wrap
your head around. Not existing,
which I definitely can't fucking do.
But the beauty of not
existing as you don't exist,
so you can't sit there thinking like,
fuck, I don't exist to him anymore.
You just don't exist.
That's it. You know, God,
I wish I was deep.
That was pathetic.
Just skimming the surface
of a bunch of cool shit.
And I just have nothing to say
because I don't read. Um, anyways,
but you ever see that shit?
You ever see some shit where uh,
it just reminds you of like,
you know,
I guess maybe to enjoy living.
I was in a hardware store and no,
I wasn't.
I was in cvs and I saw a
booster seat for the toilet
and I was just like, wow. You
know, like that, that is an option.
Like that could possibly happen to me
where I could get so fucking old that I
have the ability to lower myself
down onto a regulation height,
toilet seat.
But I lacked the quad strength to get
my in my legs to get myself back up.
You know? Gee, I mean, didn't,
well, how do you figure that?
Does that just happen one day you sit
down and then you just can't fucking get
up again and then you just have
to fucking, what do you do?
You got to fucking just sort of lean
over to one side and fall off the toilet.
Hope there's not a vanity there and
then you just laying there on the tiles.
You balls are still in the toilet water.
Yeah.
See what I'm saying? People,
this is my inspirational speech.
You've got to live life. You gotta live
life. Get a fucking dog. I'm telling you,
you're such shutdown emotional psychopath.
I cannot tell you how much
having a dog has helped me.
And in fucking two weeks
I have in this thing.
I absolutely unconditionally
fucking love this dog.
I absolutely fucking love this dog.
And uh,
I uh,
to the point and take it and you don't
in the exact thing that I was running
from the reason why I never got a dog,
like the responsibility of having one
and having a walk the fucking thing and
give it water. And if it takes a shit,
I got to pick it up in a fritos bag.
You know, and act like I'm walking to my
trash barrel when I'm really going to my
neighbors, you know, going
through all that bullshit.
That's the thing I think I love the most.
I actually like that I have a reason
to walk away from having fucking four
Scotches, you know? Now I
only have three, you know,
and then I come home half in the bag and
I start screaming at the dog about my
childhood. You know, it's
a great thing. I don't see,
I don't scream at him like it's his fault.
I just yell at it about my childhood,
you know? No, I don't do that shit.
I just like get you animal lovers up in
a fucking, get your panties in a bunch.
Do you really do that? Why would you too?
It's just a jog. It doesn't understand.
Oh no, but it's, it's, it's been a,
it's been a great thing to the point.
I'm literally,
I took it to the beach today and uh,
it's fucking hilarious.
Took it down to the water and this
thing is so goddamn like muscular.
It's ridiculous.
Like you remember those that you
don't really ever see pumping iron.
Did you ever see that when those
guys that you know that, that,
that fucking the how Kogan flex where
they, I don't know how to do it.
How the fuck to you without
visually all right, you bring it up,
right? Like in the wrestler,
bring it up. Remember that,
show up the Wii and then
you bring it back down.
You got your two fists meet and right
above your fucking pubes that shot.
Right. You know, fucking
all the muscles papa.
That's what this fucking dog
looks like when it's running.
And it was absolutely terrified of
the water in the ocean. You know,
like I was trying to get it
to go out where it was just
above its neck, you know,
you know where it's paws
weren't touching the ground.
The tide was really strong and shit.
So it was kind of,
but we kind of offsetting each other
like counterbalance and each other with
like the weight of the dog and
me. You know, a couple of times,
like the waves are like washing over
and he's doing like somersaults and shit
and uh, the thing got so fucking
scared. I'm looking at it like, dude,
you're a bull. This is pathetic. We're
on Venice beach. People are watching,
you know,
you know what's funny is people who
are really into animals actually just
believe that fucking story.
They actually believe that I went out
into the ocean with the fucking dog.
I've, I'm terrified of the fucking
ocean. Don't you guys listen to my act?
Haven't you seen any of my past specials?
I am absolutely fucking terrified
of the ocean. I will not go in it.
The only way I'll go in and
is if my boat sinks. Okay.
Or if I'm on fire. And even
then, even then, even then,
then what the fuck is that?
Even then I'll just stay in the shadow.
Shallow water can't fucking talk.
All of a sudden I used to
do a bit in my act, right?
Uh, I love how I just throw these jokes
out cause I'm never going to put them on
albums or anything like that.
I used to do this bit in my act where I
was talking about being terrified of the
ocean. You know, cause I'm
scared of sharks stare.
I'm scared of getting eaten alive and
drowning at the same time, you know,
combining, you know, like
splitting aces in a bad way,
like horrific deaths, you know. So this
guy one time, this is the joke, right?
He used to eat. This guy
says to me, trying to make me
more relaxed. Wait a minute,
is my phone ringing? Somebody breaking
my balls at the Celtics lost. Oh,
says Joe to Rosa. He doesn't give a shit.
He doesn't. You guys want to hear? Oh,
I got my first phone and call Joe de Rosa.
Hang on a second.
I'll put them on speaker.
Joe De Rosa. Joe.
Hey Dude. Hey. Hey. Shut up.
I'm doing my podcast right now.
No,
I got you on speaker.
So don't say anything fucked up.
You're going to be on my podcast. Joe De
Rosa from the uninformed show. Everybody
quite some time now with my good friend
Scott here. Okay. And, uh, I kept,
I kept talking about that drum clip where
the guy played like the 64th notes was
flight. What is that guy's
name? I gotta show it to them.
Oh, Joe. Joe Mayor.
Joe. Joe Man. Yeah. Like
John Mayer. Chip Jojo.
Uh, no, I, yeah, I don't mind. I Dunno.
I Dunno. Joe and I listen to John Mayer.
Joe, Joe Mayor. Like, like
Brittany Spears now. Um,
I think it's either within, yeah,
just, just look it up. You'll find it.
Just write Jo Jo Mayor Bass Drum and
uh, just, just watch what he does.
All right.
No, I'm going to, I'm going to watch
what he does and all your fans.
I love all of you.
And keep listening to the bill podcasts.
Hey Joel, why don't you hire
your next Gig? Get fucking drunk.
I'll be in Indianapolis this
weekend at crackers. Crackers. Yes.
If you come see me and I appreciate it.
Okay. All right. Joseph, will you
have a good night of drinking?
I'll talk to you later.
Thank you,
Bill.
Alright, that's uninformed.
Shorter rose everybody.
And I completely forgot what the
fuck I was talking about. Oh,
I was talking to him. I was going
to do that first joke. See that?
You see what he's doing?
He's just drinking. He's out
drinking on a Sunday night.
Why are you guys all don't
become comedians? Oh fuck.
Earthquake. Earthquake,
earthquake. Fuck. Hang on.
Hang on.
Well, that was a little one and I was
a little one. Okay. How about that?
A phone in a fucking earthquake
in a fucking MP3 at the
beginning of this is the
best Goddamn podcast ever.
Jesus Christ. Is that scary?
Huh?
It's so funny. You know what you're
doing when the earthquake, you just,
you just sort of stand there and you put
your fucking hands out like, like you,
you could somehow stop the energy.
Yeah. Like all of a sudden you're a,
I dunno, some superhero. They knows how to
stop the fuck. That's what I did. I said,
okay. Okay. Normally I would
actually run into the door jamb.
Wait a fucking minute. Wait
a minute. I've got a dog.
Hey Cleo,
aren't you supposed to give
me a warning about that shit?
I thought you fucking dogs knew stuff
about that. Well, we just disproved them.
Fucking meth right there.
Hang on a second. I gotta
make sure my dogs are right.
Hold on, hold on. Hold on,
Cleo. Okay, baby.
It's showing right. Get
chilling out, right.
The dog's chilling dog show is probably
just a truck driving by. I'm such a fan.
All right. Anyways, let's get back
to it's, wow. This really, okay.
You know what's funny?
Look on me working on my memory.
Thank you everybody for all your tips
out there that I can't remember what the
fuck they were and I haven't even used
them. Homeline but I'm going to use them.
I'm going to use them.
What does it Pictionary?
What the fuck am I supposed
to use? Um, I'm actually,
I should remember what I was about.
MMM.
To fuck I doing. Oh yeah, that's right.
I was still doing one. Uh, one of my,
one of my jokes I used to do,
but seven, eight years ago,
if you saw me down the comedy cellar,
you might recognize this one goes
a little something like this. Uh,
what was I talking?
Oh yeah,
this is how this guy was trying to get
me to not be freaked out about going into
the ocean and sharks. And
he goes, uh, he goes, well,
you know, so I'm bill. A lot
of people don't realize this,
but 90% of shark attacks actually
happened in the shallow water.
And My punchline was like, yeah,
that's where the people are.
It's called the beach. Stupid.
Right? Stupid little attitude.
Or wear a leather jacket.
I was dangerous back then.
What the fuck was the tat tagged to that?
I literally have to go back to
the beginning to remember. Yeah.
It's where the people are. It's
called the beach. Stupid. You know,
it's like to some guidance. Yeah. Let's,
you know, I used to mind swimming.
Let's go out. Let's go to Europe. You're
fucking pussies. That was a joke. Oh,
and the people, they would
laugh, they would laugh,
and I would get myself a free falafel.
That's what I would do when I worked at
the comedy cellar. You still food spots,
food spots back in the day, which meant
you literally were working for food.
That's how much fun my fucking job is.
I used to drive from Boston all the way
down to New York City and I used to sign
up for late night at the comedy cellar.
Uh,
and late night was in at uh,
between one and two in the morning or
two 30 in the morning and back then you
would simply sign up nine.
All,
there's a lot of young comics
right now I think in that,
that was really easy and they're
actually right because now they make them
fucking,
they got to do pre shows and they got
to bring 20 fucking people and blow
somebody. It's, it's got a bark outside.
Standing with flyers is brutal.
Back.
Back in the day you'd just
go down and you'd sign up.
But I would drive three
and a half hours down,
sign up three and a half hours back.
I knew I had to do that one time.
That was how fucking dumb I was. This is
my big way that I was going to get in,
in like at night in New York or whatever.
Just my whole way,
like I had to take baby steps when
I went to New York because I was so
intimidated when I went down to New York,
because all I had performed two was a
bunch of angry white dudes in Boston and I
wasn't angry white dude. I fucking grew
up around angry white dude. So it was, no,
it wasn't a problem. Then when I went
down in New York, everybody's there.
There was, you know, Puerto
Ricans, black people, fucking
Puerto Rican, I don't know.
Right. Blanked out. Whatever. There's
a bunch of other people there, right?
I wait a second, I saw a do rag. I'd get
like, I'd feel myself. I'd literally just,
I get back on my heels and then
there's nothing worse. Bobbing sucks.
But when you bombed because you,
you were a fucking pussy.
That's the worst kind of bombing.
If you stand there, right? Hey,
you're fucking given it right back to
them and they're just giving you shit and
you lose. But at least you told him to
go fuck themselves. Is this something,
it's still sucks. I'm not gonna lie. It's
still like a nice fucking liver shot,
but I'm telling you, it's, it's,
it hurts so much more when you're,
when you act like ned Beatty. All
right. Anyways, um, what am I doing?
What am I doing here? Whether that's
how far into this podcast out we can,
we had phone calls. We've
had fucking earthquakes. I
talked to my dog. All right.
With 39 minutes in, um, oh, coming up
this weekend. Let's, let's for once,
let me hype. Uh, let me hyper.
What the fuck I got going on?
I'm going to be at the Improv out
here in Hollywood, California.
I know a lot of people out, uh,
out West are always asking me,
when are you going to be forming in la?
Well, there you go. You sons of bitches.
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the Improv on Melrose and uh,
um, May 22nd and May 23rd,
that's a Friday and a Saturday.
Fridays at eight o'clock and Saturday
two shows seven 30 and nine 30 and be
breaking down a bunch of new material.
And we talking about my dog.
I want a fucking more on am I
don't know what I'm going to say,
but I'm imagining it's going to be
hilarious. Least I'm hoping it is.
And uh,
maybe that's what I'll do.
Maybe I'll just become that guy
who fucking, Nah, that's what I,
you know,
that's going to be a next career move.
I'm just gonna just talk about dogs
and be that guy. You know the dog guy,
he just talks about dogs.
Oh yes.
I saw that guy.
That's the best, the quickest
way to blow up. You know,
I saw the other day that there was
a, uh, you know, and I, I don't,
I don't begrudge anybody who sells
tickets here. Let me preface it with that.
But I saw that there was a
ventriloquist who was booked to play
in like this basketball arena,
like a professional basketball.
I me like where the fucking Atlanta
hawks players some shit. All right?
And God bless that guy.
He deserves every fucking dime he gets.
But this is the question I have for you.
What kind of a fucking moron sit in the
upper deck of a Goddamn arena to watch
your fucking ventriloquist. You understand
what I'm saying? I mean, what? What?
What do you say on the car ride home?
You can't do I can you see I could.
You see his lips move?
Yeah. Even when he was talking,
you couldn't see it. You dumb cunt.
You fucking one erodes away.
It was [inaudible].
It was amazing the way
he could throw his voice.
It was almost like they invented some
sort of apparatus that amplified what he
was saying because it was so loud and it
was so far away and yet I couldn't see
his lips moving. Can you imagine being
that dumb? How much fun you have?
Like how good does ice cream taste
when you're that fucking stupid?
You could ever know.
Ice Cream and enjoying a bowl of that.
Just having the time of your
life too dumb to stop eating it.
Just wondering why you keep
getting headaches. Oh, great.
Another untimely headache.
Just when I was going to enjoy
the rest of this ice cream.
Why do these untimely headaches always
have to come when I'm enjoying what I
love to do. Most eating a
whole bowl of vanilla ice cream
dot. That would be great. Just to be
that fucking stupid, you know? You know,
that's stupid. I've talked about this
before. You know, that stupid way.
Your fucking mouth is open. Even when
you're not talking. You know those people,
they just sit there and for some
reason their tongue never dries out.
Even a bulldog,
that tip of his tongue will dry out after
Wagga morons that I don't know what is
that tongue never,
never dries out.
So you've got to just sit there and
look at it. You know, it's annoying.
If it was dried out, it at least make
you feel good that there was suffering.
All right, that was a tangent. Um,
let's get back to the podcast here.
Um, all right. There was actually
some great questions here.
This is why I actually saved
these. Um, this is a great,
if you guys want to have a,
uh,
if you want to have a blueprint for a
great question. I am actually, you know,
I gotta tell you, you guys have
really stepped up in general.
I'm going to give you all a pat
on the back. You guys are really,
you're writing really funny shit in there.
They're great questions.
Like this one here. Listen
to this question. Bill.
If you were a serial killer,
how would you kill your victims and what
would be your serial killer name? Uh,
for my job,
I have a lot of time to think about stuff.
And I was listening to your story about
the Green River killer and it got me to
thinking if I was a serial killer,
how would I do it?
He's alluding to my podcast
a couple of weeks ago.
I was talking about how they always
give like Syrah killers, nicknames,
like they're playing in the fucking
Rose Bowl, you know? Uh, so anyway, so,
so he's actually actually, I know
what, that's what I did last week.
That's what the fuck I did. I looked
up a bunch of serial killer nicknames,
you know,
I noticed a lot of guys
had a great nicknames,
but there was actually a surprising
amount of female serial killers,
but not enough of them got cool nicknames
except for this one lady who was known
as the giggling grandmother.
And uh, I can't recall,
there was a couple of weeks ago, but
she literally killed like four husbands,
both her sisters as second cousin or
whatever. And they finally, you know,
figured out what the fuck was going on.
Do you mind a shit you could get
away with back in the day? You know,
nowadays you got to kill like 22 complete
strangers back in the day before they
knew how to dust for fingerprints and
they didn't have all this fucking DNA
investigation. You could literally
kill everybody at work. You know,
you work with 40 people
in 40 weekends in a row.
Somebody could be disappearing and you
could literally just keep shrugging your
shoulders going, ah, I dunno. Here.
I mean, yet. What are the odds? Yes.
Um,
so anyways,
when they finally picked up this
old lady and they interrogated her,
I guess she would just laugh when
they would, did you kill him?
And she would just sort of
laugh and say, yeah, I did.
And they tell if she was just trying
to mask her embarrassment or if she was
just that shutdown or whatever.
But she got the nickname,
the giggling grandmother. That's
a great one. That's a great one.
The giggling grammar.
Literations grandmothers,
she supposed to be making cookies
and she's out killing people.
Gives you a chill. It's fucking beautiful.
So anyways, let's get back to this.
So this guy says he feet sat around
thinking about it at work and a, okay,
here's this deal. He said, not to sound
too crazy, but I did give it to some give,
did give it some thought as how
I would kill somebody. He said,
I figured I would use a stick I
found in the forest and sharpen it,
use it, and then burn the evidence. I
would be the caveman killer. And Dude,
I gotta tell you, that's
just fucking great. That's
just really well thought out.
How fucking awesome is that all these
guys for years in the mob, you know,
they tape up the gun with duck tape and
then they shoot the dude and then they
throw it in the fucking river and then
some fucking nerd who never gets any
pussy. Who's got time to use a metal
detector at the bottom of the river,
finds the fucking thing.
And next thing you know,
you get busted at your 30 year
fucking high school graduation, right?
Happens all the time. This is perfect.
This is perfect. If you kill somebody,
you don't even know what the sharpened
stick, you burn the fucking stick.
This is so good. I don't even want to
fucking, I don't even want to like, like,
like talk about it. I'm afraid
I'm giving somebody a great idea.
So let's get to me. How would I do it and
what my serial killer name would be? Um,
well if you know me, um,
I'm a big fan of yesteryear.
I'm not looking forward to the future.
So I would go old school, you know,
I would go old school. I try to
bring back the cycle, you know,
I would use a sickle and uh,
and I would definitely get into
the placement of the body. Okay.
We'll just be me because I learned from
a cop that the more people you involve
in a crime,
the higher chance you have of getting
caught because somebody is going to be
that fucking more on like that kid.
I mean that fucking kid in a,
was it Saturday night fever when he
doesn't jump in on the fight? Well,
will you guys, oh, I was looking for
you. There's always one of those guys,
you know, and that, you
know, they just start crying.
I was with this guy,
he's fucking work in the
fucking Improv next weekend. Um,
so I would definitely do it alone and I
would bring back the second I would wear
the hood and I would do all that
type and I wouldn't wear the hood.
Just make me all sweaty. I'm going to
kill him. Who cares what they see my face.
And basically what I would do is I would
just fucking chop their heads off and I
would leave the head in their bed and
I'd leave their body in the bathtub and I
would be known as the, uh,
bed bath and be header.
Can I,
can I just apologize for that?
I really knew that that was going to stink
as though as I was starting to say it
, I knew that that was going to
be awful, but I dunno, I was just,
I was trying to fucking,
I hate corporations and if there was just
a way that you could go around killing
people and to have it kind of sound like
best buy or bed bath and beyond just so
some fucking douchebag
would have to actually stand
behind a podium and actually
read some letter of detraction going,
we don't down,
we here at bed,
bath and beyond.
Do not condone let the bed bath and
be header does. Uh, we don't condone,
um, even just assaulting people. Once
again, we are bed bath and beyond. We,
there's no be heading that
happens here. And, um,
I know he's still on the loose,
but I think it's safe to say that he does
not work for us and we are cooperating
with the local authorities,
have answered all their questions and
that's all we have to say on the matter.
And we would just like to get back
to selling pillow cases, you know,
just to make them fucking do
that. All right, there you go.
There's a podcast for the week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
A lot of thrills, lot of spills. Have
little earthquake. Little, a little,
a little bit of everything.
I hope I was able to edit that MP three
in the front of this because I recorded
this fucking thing first,
you know, so, uh, that's it. Please
come out and see me at the, uh,
the Improv this week and I'm trying
to put together none but another,
a Monday show up at the
punchline in San Francisco. Uh,
I had so much fun last March doing that
and that's what I got going on. And, uh,
congratulations to the people
down there in Orlando. Uh,
you've got a great basketball team.
You'd beat my Celtics.
Congratulations to you guys.
You know you've got something better
to do than fucking put steel balls
underneath your fucking pickup truck and
drive over to Epcot center, you know,
or have a wild weekend down
there in Tampa. Huh? You know,
or just sit around watching your
mullets grow. You know, you got,
you go into the fucking eastern
conference finals. Who Do you guys like?
Who Do you like?
I got to tell you,
I'm rooting for the fucking nuggets
and I'm living out here in la.
I really, I really,
you know, I don't hate,
I don't hate Laker fans cause
it's like they live here,
so obviously they're
fucking in the Lakers.
But what I do hate is how they're acting
like they're anywhere near the amount
of championships at the Celtics
have. It's like, dude, you have nine.
The Los Angeles Lakers have nine
championships. Okay. Stop with this.
14 the Minneapolis Lakers
one five. Okay. Your, your,
your, your franchise has
one 14 I'll give you that.
If you take two cities and you
glue them together, they have won.
You've won three less championships
than the one city of Boston has one.
Don't ever fucking forget that.
All right?
Cause if the Lakers ever moved to fucking
Los Vegas and they won a championship,
how would you think of some Douche
bag? And Vegas was like, yeah,
we got 15 bitches. It's
like, no you don't. No,
you got one. You got one.
All right, so you fuckers,
you're still in single digits and you're
going to lose some of the nuggets.
At least I hope you do. I hope
you don't show up. Hope you know,
I don't know why the Lakers aren't
showing up. This is easy for them.
Kevin Gara nets out. Bam. It's
wide open. You're good to go.
The Cavaliers do not have enough
guys on their team to beat you guys.
The nuggets don't have enough guys.
But you know what?
The nuggets and the Cavaliers have that
the Lakers don't have. They have heart.
They got fucking heart. I'm telling
you the lady who the fuck takes,
who takes games off in the playoffs?
Who does that? Who does that?
The fucking Los Angeles Lakers. It's
almost like this. So fucking good.
They just stay, uh, let's fuck
around. I Dunno. I don't fuck it.
No, I'm just, you know, I
don't know. I bombed. My team
lost, but you know something.
The can somebody in the NBA just
called traveling? I don't give a fuck.
Even if it's on my own.
I saw, I saw fucking, oh,
what's his face there tonight?
The fuck am I trying to think.
I'm already thinking. I, I,
they just suck with names.
Just pause, Bill. Think that Ray Lewis,
he plays for the fucking Ray Allen.
Jesus Christ. I'm getting old here.
I've seen out ray Allen literally
catches a ball. He runs three steps,
clearly runs three steps and takes
the three pointer and hits it.
The amount of times I
just sit there and scream.
Traveling as I watch an NBA game is,
it's ridiculous.
He wants ridiculous as I continue
this podcast, even though it was over.
It's over. All right. You guys get on
with your lives, your lives, your lives.
What a fucking moron. All right. You
guys have a good week. God bless.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].